la Cumbre de París para un nuevo pacto
financiero mundial llega a su fin los
cuarenta jefes de estado y líderes de
gobierno invitados llegaron a acuerdos
de financiación Con promesas como cien
mil millones de dólares de los países
ricos o 200.000 millones de dólares de
entidades como el Banco Mundial para los
países en vías de desarrollo Francia
país anfitrión pidió introducir
impuestos internacionales sobre las
transacciones financieras en los
billetes de avión y el transporte
marítimo para luchar contra la crisis
climática pero también contra la pobreza
necesitamos reformar radicalmente la
gobernanza de la arquitectura financiera
internacional para que sea más eficiente
más justa y esté mejora adaptada al
mundo actual
pero a pesar de los acuerdos aún no hay
un consenso claro y el dinero sigue
siendo un tema de discusión los 100.000
millones de dólares prometidos están muy
por debajo de las necesidades de los
países a más pobres para luchar contra
los impactos del calentamiento global y
países como Brasil con el mayor bosque
húmedo del mundo consideran que los más
ricos Son los únicos que tienen
representación en las instituciones
internacionales
si no hay no discutir
si no debatimos la cuestión de la
desigualdad y no le damos tanta
prioridad como a la cuestión climática
podemos tener un clima muy bueno
pero la gente se seguirá muriendo de
hambre en varios países del mundo
los países más ricos del mundo como
Estados Unidos o china son los que más
contaminan pero los más pobres son los
que enfrentarán las mayores
consecuencias de la crisis climática y
con esta Cumbre y la copa 28 que se
celebrará a finales de año en Dubai las
naciones más afectadas quieren intentar
cambiar eso